what tv series would you love to guest
star on
gosh uh euphoria
um
i know i think they're on the last
season peaky blinders what movie or
movies do you think you've seen the most
the movie i've seen the most is
definitely the dark knight
[Laughter]
honestly i've seen 10 things i hate
about you a good amount of times for
sure and then i think uh she's all that
falls right there because i watched it a
lot of times prepping for this too
actually i can imagine that um
is there anything that you guys collect
basically cars guitars and motorcycles
that's though that's my saying that's
those are my three things that i kind of
i i definitely have too many of um i
definitely collect like this is weird
but like like sentimental clothing items
i feel like i like to like
this is also really weird because i like
to like when a friend like lets me like
have a shirt she's like oh yeah you can
keep it and i'm like oh my gosh awesome
never gonna forget this person i like to
keep people's shirts that's really weird
but like it also just is like something
that's like valuable and friendships i
feel like whenever someone gives me um
like an article of clothing i like never
want to forget it
i i actually think that is very sweet um
jumping a little bit into the movie with
the karaoke scene what is your go-to
karaoke song in real life i say since
you've been gone kelly clarkson is like
is a great one but uh
also call me maybe by carly rey jepson
that was just really fun so i'll say
that one too uh don't you
you by the way wow
don't you which girlfriend is hot like
me let's do that that's my new goat
i would like to see video of this please
post um okay um so you guys are both on
instagram obviously and i am curious how
much do you debate
right before you hit the post button on
what i'm about to post are you in your
head at all or is it sort of like yeah
just
it goes
it's it's
it's progressively changed for me um but
in the beginning i feel like i
definitely contemplated like oh my gosh
you know i have to zoom in on every inch
and see you know are people gonna say
something mean about this or uh point
out this and i feel like insecurities at
the time were a big thing for me to like
be hesitant but now i really feel like
if i love a photo and it represents me
and what i love and enjoy i'm just i'm
like you know what post it if people
don't like it they don't like it i enjoy
it i love it and it is a reflection of
me so yeah i'm i'm i'm the same way i'm
kind of like if i like a photo if you
don't like it
hey that's fine if you like it that's
great
you know you want to comment on it go
for it so i just kind of just pick a
picture and i'm like this seems good yep
let's go
that's the move now
i am curious um so you meet mark waters
for the first time how many minutes did
it take before you started bringing up
mean girls oh my gosh i so mark and i
met and we went like to this little
bitty like restaurant it was super cute
and um we went and probably within the
first three to five minutes
realistically i brought it up i mean
what an iconic movie and mark is an
incredible incredible director so he's
kind of a must i mean give him a nod and
you know say wow you are incredible if
that's all i have to say it
you know funny enough i didn't i didn't
bring up mean girls really no freaky
friends i brought up freaky friday
friday that was the one for me
freaky friday is an incredible movie
yeah
right i i the thing i i think is that
you don't want to pull the chris farley
and be like remember when you did that
movie and at the same time you want to
sort of geek out about it because these
are awesome movies yeah
you know uh i but i am curious so
addison this is your first feature film
if you could go back in time on day one
what do you wish you knew
from making the movie be more present
with you know everyone around me i think
i i really um dove right in when it came
to my character but i wish i had been a
little more present with the cast and
and crew and just i feel like been a
little more like
yeah like more more involved in that
entire outside world i feel like i was
also really nervous i would go back to
my trailer and be like okay time to read
over this a million times but i think i
i should trust myself a little bit more
maybe that maybe trust yourself a little
more trust your gut and um and enjoy the
time on set it is your first movie and i
could totally understand being in your
head a little bit being like i've got to
do this
yeah you know
for sure
for both of you guys i love learning
about the behind the scenes of the
making of a movie for soon to be fans
what do you think they might be
surprised to learn about the making of
the movie it was freezing cold so many
nights it was yeah there was a lot of
night shoots that we did um
specifically
at the gatsby party when you had to
yeah
there's some i get extremely wet um and
um i actually ended up having to get
into the shower in a full
suit
um
funny enough you can't even see that the
suit's really wet
um
but i spent like six hours from like 12
a.m to 6 a.m
uh and that was one of the colder nights
in la and i think it was probably like
40 to 45 degrees out i'm just shivering
soaking wet in a suit that i can't take
off and we also like i don't know how
much how many you had but those hand
warmers literally was like sticking them
under my feet in my shoe lining them
under my foot lining them in my like
arms any chance i got those hand warmers
were literally glued to my skin it was
so cold i can only imagine what you were
feeling yeah it wasn't pleasant it
wasn't pleasant that's for sure
see so you're saying that making movies
is not glamorous
i mean hey is anything all glamorous all
the time we're doing what we love so
that's great but there's definitely days
that it it can feel like a job you know
no 100 i've been on sets i see the way
it is um yeah so my last question it's
an individual for each of you um addison
i'm curious if making movies is
something that you want to pursue more
in the future if you're reading scripts
what are you thinking about and uh i'm
kind of a fan of this cobra kai show and
so i'm kind of curious what you can
tease about the upcoming season
so for me yes um this is only the
beginning for me i'm continuing now to
read scripts um self tapes auditions
everything that i can to continue and
hopefully many many more to come this is
a big passion of mine and yeah like i
said this is just the beginning
um
cobra kai season four
uh
all i can say is that the world is
getting much
much bigger
and it's just it's it's it's it's
getting crazier than ever
um specifically obviously the teaser
came out about the uh the all valley
again
this season so i think uh i think a lot
of people are gonna enjoy that yeah we
we got pretty uh pretty crazy with it we
know the stakes had to be higher so we
all trained really really hard the
fighting's uh better than ever so i
think a lot of people are gonna be
surprised but extremely happy
cannot wait again it's gonna be a big
hit for you guys thank you for giving me
your time and indulging my questions
have a great day thank you thank you so
much